howard i got some breaking news and i'm
really down in the dumps about it uh fan
texting me this is from andy on
instagram hi marian been a big fan for
the past 15 years wanted to let you know
i've been feeding bobo questions via
facebook messaging for the past couple
of years
i am in shock i'm shaking i can't
believe i'm so upset about it are you
saying
that bobo has a ghostwriter he doesn't
write his own questions is he on the
line today i doubt it he knows he's
wrong
he's not on the line oh he knows because
i confronted him last night i said how
could you hold on mary and breaking news
i have a guy named andy on the phone
real who claims he is the andy andy are
you the uh andy in question that
marianne says has been writing for bobo
for years hi howard hi robin yeah i'm
andy
took an interest in bobo when i heard he
was moving down here to central florida
and just like a lot of listeners if i
came up with an idea or something i'd
want to call but i just never had the
time or the courage so i would start
throwing topics over to bobo's way and
every now and then i'd hear my topic on
the air and i thought hmm kind of
interesting but he's taken all the
credit for it and then yesterday you
know everyone was praising him marianne
said good job he was patting himself on
the back but those aren't even his
questions well andy you've just uh
lit a little bomb off
taking credit for bobo's questions is
like bragging about being gary's
pitching coach
it's maybe something you don't even want
to take credit for but you know
plagiarism is taken very seriously here
he confirmed it on my text last night he
said he did it
wow robin there's already a confession
on the book
the fact that he's been saying so so
much i crafted my questions
millions of legal pads you know how is
we got to do something i want him to
give up his cameo i want him to be off
until september i don't want him back
out this is like a travesty i'm just the
tip of the iceberg yeah i can't be the
only one it's about all the other people
all over the country that are messaging
him it's getting a little bit for me a
little bit from them
on our phone ladies and gentlemen
to answer these accusations
is bobo
bobo what is this i'm hearing that you
have been using a ghostwriter for years
and not giving him credit
first of all he sent things to me
questions he goes i can't call up
because if you want to use it so i said
yeah i'll look at it some of them i use
some of them i don't know i just never
gave him credit bobo you never said that
he didn't want credit he never said he
didn't want credit why didn't you say
howard this isn't a question i crafted
first of all i now have to apologize to
my audience first of all for those of
you out there who thought bobo was
writing his own questions i sincerely
apologize i i tell you i did not know
i'm willing to take a lie detector test
he writes to andy i got all the texts
hey andy i like what you wrote i will
put it into my rotation of questions
thanks hit me up anytime what do you
have to say about that bobo i'm reading
it right
well hold on now on our phone is high
pitch eric who wants to say something
about this yes high pitch howard i think
all of us will be banned for four months
by doing this
high pitcher is calling for another ban
of four months now
now it hits more thank you buddy i'll
call with that tomorrow i love it thank
you for sending to me i really
appreciate it it's getting harder to
come up with good air material do you
believe that he's stupid enough to text
fans with this
nice enough to send it to me i don't
blow them off i love my fans
again they're always your fans guess
what they're howard's fans nobody gives
a [ __ ] about you and me
this will yeah our last conversation
because do not get in touch with me you
lost a friend you're a liar you know
what it is
yeah
yo i'm not wide like that you're not
right you're not white ass all right cut
marion off jeff the drunk wants to weigh
in how do you feel about this jeff
bobo should be banned until the end of
your time
wow you know
this is your big phone call that i
should be banned [ __ ] ass wife you
never come up with anything i'll have
people like perfect maybe you should
my fan andy do you mind writing for jeff
the drunk a little bit
i'll see if i can get some good
questions all right let's leave it at
that it's been exposed i'm sure there's
going to be a lot of people writing in
about this april 27th 2022 a date that
will live in infamy
where we learn that bobo doesn't write
all his own questions
and we'll see how this plays out okay
bobo
okay it is shocking i'm really sitting
here
shocked how dare you that anyone was
helping with those crazy questions